ah
what's to make one episode of world's
toughest fixes requires weeks of
preparation production and editor
there's girl gentlemen actually
roll Aria for a minute you see on TV
hours were spent working on and off the
camp the attacks in villa drilling
Florida Barge everybody's doing their
job sound guys Micah people caravans
filming I'm probably the pump boss is
busting my balls yeah it's all are doing
what it should be doing
once a fix is located Riley in the field
to hit the road or the river to capture
all the action
that means getting everything pulled
that thing you're standing on right
first step to having lunch is finding
each and every detail of the tough fix
I'm supposed to jump in line so I can
get lunch so they fill me apparently me
eating lunch is fascinating and
everybody wants to see I'm Sean Ryan the
crew has to make sure that every scene
has a tape that the editor can choose
from to use in the show okay my hands
are buried up to the elbow in the mind
that's how I'm not floating away the
Mississippi River the takes that aren't
used are called
outtakes and end up on the cutting room
floor I really want to take a sing-off
man it's killing me getting the best
take isn't easy
nice
Hey
that's awesome
I just had this conversation you guys
are right in the way yep this show is
even more challenging because to prove
shared the same works I will pass on you
Brian I got a can for you too dedication
yeah this is like a dairy farm out here
smells like poo
welding hot and it's all taking place on
the mighty and muddy Mississippi River
big right ladies and gentlemen takes one
for the team
who's the shoe in the muck Keith on
recording sound doesn't miss a beat the
guy's a machine
on this shoot about 300 tons came
dangerously close to squashing the whole
crew
our next slide towards us right now
working hard under hazardous
circumstances can take its toll not the
kind of place you want to fall over it's
important to find ways to let off steam
kiss and make a better there's a
soundman restroom wow you think you
could do my makeup - at the end of a
long day the crew heads to bed to rest
up for another day working on the
world's toughest fixes oh goodness I
hunt you know what's there if I'm what
Wow
that shows up on YouTube I'm suing how
are you